pour l'instant québon jour deux arts de
pandémie vous comment je pose la
question des gens qu'on n'a pas vue
depuis un bout de temps comment vous
avez vécu seul d'abord d'enlever profité
pour manifestement écrire oui oui je me
suis lancé là dedans pour meubler mai
journée et
j'étais
à côté que j'étais très content de pas
être dérangé bien sûr j'étais très
inquiets par l'épidémie mais ça m'a
permis de de pondre quelques bouquins
qui dormaient dans dans ma tête depuis
quelques temps et celui ci
émerveillement
c'est un plaidoyer
pour garder notre capacité
d'émerveillement parce que ça vous
inquiète un peu vous on est trop blasés
il faut continuer à ces merveilles oui
les gens on dirait qu'ils ont oublié ça
ils trouvent ça enfantin
simpliste si vous faites le pessimiste
si vous critiquez si vous êtes sceptique
ah oui ça va mais quelqu'un qui sied à
merveille
c'est de plus en plus rares c'est un
hommage aussi à la curiosité parce que
vous comment vous décrire vous êtes
évidemment éditeur vous êtes journaliste
vous êtes animateur
dans le fond c'est le même moteur que
vous avez fait avancer c'est la
curiosité oui le nouveau le widi oui en
fait c'est si dans tous les métiers que
j'ai fait c'est le journalisme qui prime
c'est ici parce qu'au départ je suis un
journaliste est bon et de maisons
d'édition j'ai dirigé ça comme j'aurais
diriger un journal il production que
j'ai fait pareil
séché toujours été curieux
d'en apprendre et d'être un peu
de découvrir des choses de la croix de
transmission et de transmettre aux
autres ce que j'ai appris que c'était un
peu mon moteur
si à l'instant qui est un brillant
touche à tout l'édition les livres
restent le coeur de sa vie
professionnelle
les éditions à l'instant qui ont publié
2000 titres de 75 à 1997 année au
quebecor le rachète lui-même en a écrit
une trentaine
est à son image la maison d'édition
ratisse large la littérature avec abriel
roi ou victor lévy beaulieu des manuels
pratiques des essais mais c'est un livre
de mémoires celle de richard nixon qui
reste son meilleur coup le loup
canadiens comme l'a baptisé le figaro va
coiffer tous les éditeurs parisiens et
obtenir les droits mondiaux en français
des mémoires de l'ex président
ce tank et 11 et mais s'emmêle dollars
sur la table plus que tous ses
concurrents mais vous savez le plus
drôle c'est que je les avais pas les 100
milles à l'heure
c'est drôle ça l'air prétentieux mais
j'ai toujours pensé que si je veux
vraiment quelque chose je peux la voir
j'ai toujours pensé ça et je travaille
pour
les gens voient sans doute la bonne
intention n'y a pas de malice il ya pas
deux j'exploite personnes ils sentent
qu'ils sont en confiance et je croyais
il ya des ondes qui passe moi j'ai suivi
de leçon que mon père m'avait donné que
j'étais tout jeune j'ai dit tu regarde
avec les yeux mais tu vois avec ton
coeur alors si tu applique cette règle
là partout tu ça va des 10 et c'est vrai
cette sensibilité cette capacité de se
connecter avec le coeur comme il le dit
lui a permis de vivre de grands et
petits moments précieux avec des
personnages comme salvador dali
frédéric dard edith piaf
kadhafi des anecdotes qui ne sont jamais
insignifiante à ses yeux comme celle
avec le grand peintre jean paul lemieux
c'est une toile qui était devant une
dizaine de pieds de long qui s'appelle
envahisseurs la toile représente un fond
complètement blanc donc la neige et les
thorax de deux soldats russes parce
qu'on voit juste l'uniforme vert et une
étoile rouge c'est tout mais comme la
toile y est longue il avait évalué à 120
milles de la rue du mont amène un ami
des
animaux
alors email et mme lemon envoie porté
par un de mes amis je déroule la toile
et toute la peinture blanche craquer ton
par terre c'est une désastre la toile
est foutue vraiment
mieux qui s'est décomposé devant vous
oui c'est effrayant en ouvrant la crypte
ces tempêtes comme la neige la neige
alors je pense je sais pas quoi faire je
prends le téléphone j'appelle madeleine
sa femme en espérant qu'elle lui tira la
mauvaise nouvelle aux balles ni je pense
que je quitte roulier de toile alors
mais j'aime autant que vous le disiez
vous même à paul
et à rivière noire
à dos ça va vous avez ainsi les squales
je dis oui mais je dis un problème point
il vous les aimez pas non c'est pas ça
non c'est celle-là la blanche quand j'ai
ouverte toute ta peinture blanche est
tombé à l'eau
un reproche à l'eau
dit oui il n'avait dû blanche est bon
d'y aller acheter du blanc
seing du ciel
un homme ça fait partie de ces anecdotes
extraordinaire que vous racontez dans ce
livre l'édition alain stanké j'ai fait
une entrevue avec andré perry récemment
et malheureusement on constate que la
musique et l'industrie de la musique ça
va pas bien du tout par contre dans
votre cas les maisons d'édition 18 %
d'augmentation des ventes de livres
québécois cette année 16 % pour tous les
livres bon bien sûr et la pandémie mais
l'industrie de l'édition va bien oui oui
absolument
c'est sûr que les gens que vous deux
vous enfin ceux qui savent lire
qu'ils fassent une 20 ont fermé à la
maison ou bien regarder la télé c'est
surtout pour toujours la regarder non
plus et le livre il a il a repris sa sa
place ouais mon fils n une compagnie de
deux livres audio
ça jamais aussi bien marché que
maintenant les gens écoutent ou lise
cccc rassurant c c'est rassurant vous
rassure ah oui absolument pas ce que
l'on disait séverine a fini lui livre
fini c'est fini
alain stanké aînés en lituanie dans une
famille aisée puis coup sur coup deux
chocs
l'occupation soviétique en 1940 où sa
famille échappe à la déportation en
sibérie et les nazis en 44 les environs
dans un horrible camp de travail en
allemagne alain stanké alors dix ans cet
événement alors vous a quand même
changé je sais pas mais vous a permis
d'apprécier encore plus la vie je crois
que tous ceux qui ont approché le moron
vivent différemment partir du moment
qu'ils ont senti cette menace ça me
rappelle le voyez des techniques pour
éviter de penser qu'on va mourir y en a
une que je vais développer malgré moi on
était dans ce conte consciencieux il a
été bombardé la maison s'est écroulée
mais avant avant que la maison ne
s'écroule on voyait par la petite
lucarne et les avions qui s'approchait
bombardé une zone au sud se rapprocher
se rapprocher puis là on était sûrs que
le prochain coup ça serait notre notre
tour et je me souviens coeur s'est mis à
battre tellement fort gênant ça y est
comment comment je vais mourir et là
j'ai imaginé je ne sais pas si c'est
venu spontanément
que je voyais devant moi non pas des des
bombes qui tombaient un chant plein de
fleurs et des aidants et j'entendais pas
les éclats d'obus j'entendais pas du
tout les bombes mais j'entendais une
musique mais belle musique
extraordinaire alors je me suis inventé
une histoire
qui m'a peut-être empêché de devenir fou
parce que je sais c'est effrayant comme
quand on sent bon ça y est ça arrive
c'est tantôt c'est le pouvoir de
l'imagination
oui
[Musique]
et fort heureusement ces américains qui
sont arrivés
la guerre est finie il y avait fini
oui c'était les laisser libres premier
mot que j'ai repris en français ça vous
êtes à l'instant qu'est que vous
n'aimiez pas les uniformes et quand vous
aviez vu cet nouvel uniforme vert
c'était les américains nous avons
entendu la guerre est finie que ça a
changé votre perception
ouais c'est un la porte s'est ouverte
udine manger roi
c'est très présent dans la tête des
bilans un soldat qui est eric un foulard
en soie
et puis la lettre science emblématique
la lettre a ici seront son bataillon
lettres etc
c'était du plus beau jour de ma vie
c'était du merapi quand on regarde il
tant de choses qui aurait pu arriver et
qu'on a échappé
ce grand héros la ville le vol en
hollande a consacré une des sept plus
grandes avenues
alors puis si de l'autre côté de l'océan
au québec on l'a simplement trouvé une
petite pierre qui sont infectés on a
gravé son nom est dedans sa naissance et
samba
alain stanké fasciné par ces héros de
guerre qui n'ont pas la notoriété qu'il
mérite il en a fait un livre parmi ces
personnages les aux majors mieux connu
heureusement aujourd'hui blessé lors du
débarquement va à lui seul libérer un
village de hollande où l'histoire du
commandant stanislas déry de québec qui
en décembre 44 colin sous-marins ennemis
mais recueille les marais allemand
plutôt de les tuer une leçon de vie le
pardon et la compassion
vous dites que ça vous a pris 60 ans
avant de pouvoir pardonner
ou peuple alban et vous l'avez fait
grâce à une seule autre histoire
extraordinaire oui militaires canadiens
qui est qu'il n'a pas tiré sur des
militaires allemands cette année c est
dire il tournait autour de l'urne inde
et il a vu sur le radar bon la présence
d'un sous-marin allemand a lancé le
premier tir qui gagnent entre les duels
au baffie tire bien sûr il touche le
fumeur
[Musique]
le sous-marin sort de l'eau et du coup
tu y souffle emma un saute à l'eau avec
des gilets de sauvetage c'est glacial
c'est froid ce qu'on fait dans ce temps
là pour abréger leurs souffrances on
sort les fusils pions on les tirs et il
a crié ne tirez pas et plutôt que de les
laisser mourir il les a pris à bord de
son bateau c'est qu'on pouvait pas faire
parce que ses troupes tipi trop
dangereux mais il l'a fait quand même il
a sauvé la vie de
5,53 trois marins et à cause de la
convention de genève le capitaine
allemand devait coucher dans la cabine
du capitaine canadien etc c'est la règle
et mais ils ont trois ou quatre jours à
faire avant d'arriver à un camp de
prisonniers il y est depuis en discute
et deviennent amis écoutent la musique
prenait un coup et après la guerre ils
se sont revus ils sont restés amis
pendant 28 ans il y en a un qui est
l'équipe québec claude aller à munich
c'est quand on voit une chose comme ça
on peut pas on peut pas en vouloir
éternellement y l'uniforme des changes
parce que l'homme mais reste le même
à l'instant qui a revêtu plusieurs
uniformes dans sa vie on le voit ici
animer ce qui deviendra un classique de
la télévision les insolences d'une
caméra
à
il a touché à beaucoup de choses même le
bois qui sculptent en y inventant des
livres toujours avec ce même goût pour
l'aventuré pour l'audace mais toujours
pas très loin ce goût de rire on dit
c'est le cliché le mek les peuples qui
ont beaucoup souffert développe un
humour extraordinaire parce que l'humour
une soupape son antidote au désespoir
l'humour ou s'il devait parler
d'imagination quand vous étiez petit
dans le camp c'est tout seul qui qui qui
a jamais arrêté dans votre cerveau c'est
ça c'est sûr mais lee moore a beaucoup
beaucoup
sauver
me sauver et sauver notre dans des
situations tragiques oui
au moment où je suis arrivé en france je
parlais pas français vraiment vous
première dictée que quand on m'a fait
faire je me souviens je fais ça en deux
fois
je me suis fait rire de moi et ça m'a
tellement blessy j'ai regardé j'ai dit
un jour je parle le plus mais française
que vous pu vous m'aiderez
et vous vous avez eue parlant des
frontières la chance d'être accueillis
par la france sortir de l'allemagne
quand vous voyez ces débats sur les
migrants comment vos rires ça c'est que
gg
j'en ai parfois des larmes aux yeux de
jeu quand je vois six migrants qui ce
qu'ils sont dans des salles ou de
fortune pour traverser pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi c'est pourquoi on les
accueillir et pas non non non peut pas à
pas si on n'a pas ça et que d'amis
d'harricana militaire attend l être
humain il est où là dedans on a oublié
que ce sont des humains non non non le
plus important d'avoir le passeport avec
le le cachet dessus puis la frontière
alors allé chez nous là
je pourrai jamais que j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de difficulté avec ça
quand je vais voir la lune chez eux pour
chasser les immigrants le mi6
d'effrayant
et ce discours
qui montrent
davantage de repli sur soi justement que
ce soit aux états unis en europe on les
voit peu pareil ça vous inquiète oui
je le trouve rétrograde stupide inhumain
c'est le contraire qu'on devrait faire
de demande devrait en devrait vraiment
ouvrir ses bras la thyroxine ou surtout
pas demain mais je ferai orbi des
migrants mais j'ai un piano à queue dans
sa noria pas de places est limité
désespérant pour déterminer avec quelque
chose de plus gai mais j'avais terminé
en vous disant que votre livre
émerveillement et guy justement parce
que il nous fait comprendre à quel point
et bien sûr vous avez vu les grands
personnages mais des rencontres très
simple très humaine ou si vous ont
marqué pour la vie c'est ça c'est
d'aller au devant des gens vous lisiez
avec le choeur les yeux ouverts mais
avec le coeur moi je pense que tout le
monde tout le monde est grand gtc c'est
c'est pas
j'ai horreur du terme ou ses ont dit des
fois les gens ordinaires qui est
personne qui est anti naît on a tendance
à dire sur monsieur lui jordi des voies
ordinaires
tout le monde est extraordinaire
voilà et vous n'avez jamais regardé les
gens de où justement que vous avez fait
toutes sortes de choses publier toutes
sortes de livres vous n'avez pas daigné
archi que la grande littérature
classique c'est on ouvre les bras oui
oui on raconte des histoires sont
racontées en europe a braconné soir à
tout le monde oui mais son audition
c'est
une scène de théâtre et puis on vient
interpréter
la pièce qu'on veut
il y en a qui se dit jenny et d'autres
moins - bruins ont du succès ou pas
vous avez pour réussir en édition on dit
qu'il ya et il ya trois règles
pour même s'ils vont les cadets pas
voyez vous m'avez fait rire pour la fin
ça résume tout est ok merci
alain stanké bonsoir merci d'être sur
notre plateau évidemment quand on a
tourné tout ça c'était avant oui c'était
avant l'invasion russe c'était avant ces
images de déplacés de
2,5 millions d'ukrainiens qui ont dû
quitter leur pays vos propos sur la
guerre prennent une autre teneur
évidemment un autre sens qu'est-ce vous
réaction quand vous avez vu ça arrive et
puis je ne pensais pas que ça arriverait
vraiment je ne juge je ne pensais pas je
j'espérais que ça arriverait pas j'avais
évacuer 2 qui lie et en plus tous les
souvenirs que j'ai vécu quand j'ai été
bon mais d'abord réfugié aussi je me
suis quand je vois à la télévision des
petits garçons qui courent avec son
enceinte j'étais ce petit garçon il ya
eu un sac moi j'avais mon cou un petit
sac avec mon beau monde baptistère on ou
du cal mon père avait écrit quelques
adresses d'amis de parents à l'étranger
et puis la langue du chapelet pour prier
pour qu'un miracle arrêt mercredi
l'arrivée parce que je suis resté vivant
mais
messi si c'est un tracé jeu à l'âge de 5
ans j'ai expérimenté le peloton
d'exécution à la dernière seconde on n'a
pas tiré
après ça je me souviens très bien que
j'ai fait je sais plus où est ce que
j'allais mourir c'est effrayant
mais je pense avoir enterré tout ça
parce que ça me reviendrait pas et à la
première sirène que j'ai entendu à la
télévision en ukraine tout m'est revenue
tout quand j'ai vu ces enfants qui
couraient ces personnes qui se cachent
et je me suis terrée soudain les sous
terrains pendant des jours et des nuits
à tel point tellement souvent en france
à de possibles c'était le jour ou la
nuit on ne serait pas en est entre leurs
rangs très vite ils bombent arrive on a
appris des choses par exemple quand une
bombe explose si on entend les
sifflements sait qu'elle va pas tomber
ce robot mais si on entend l'explosion
ait plus rien après méfiez-vous elle
tombe sur vous voilà excusez moi je dis
non mais c'est des gens comme vous qui
avez connu la deuxième guerre de revoir
un théâtre de guerre en europe
c'est hallucinant a écouté depuis 1900
on a eu son 120 millions de morts pas
juste par des fous qui dirigeait les
piles et staline hitler mao tsé toung on
n'a rien appris on n'apprend rien et moi
ce que je trouve pénible ont tout le
monde a le le mot je t'aime ukraine on
est avec vous à la bouche tout va et
qu'il est dans le coeur vraiment parce
que c'est pas ce qui se passe toujours
regarder je me suis dit qu'est ce que le
canada peut faire d'un seul coup on
annonce et oui dans quinze jours on va
ouvrir les frontières on va accepter les
réfugiés oui c'est comme une maison est
en feu les gens sont en danger de mort
ont dû patienter donc un jour on nous
envoie les pompiers si tout de suite
c'est pas des
fonctionnaires avec la mentalité tampon
les papiers à remplir si on sait pas ce
que c'est l'urgence sans si on l'a pas
vécu le d'angine mans ce que vous avez
vécu aussi parce que on le dit dans le
reportage où j'ai tenu en lituanie où
j'avais votre petit enfants jusqu'à 10
ans la lituanie les pays baltes collé
sur la russie sur l'urss à l'époque donc
cette menace des russes
soviétique vous la connaissez bien et là
vous là revivez en regardant les
ukrainiens mais je sais que ça si s'ils
réussissent en ukraine rien ne les
arrêtera ils vont aller en lettonie en
lituanie en estonie s'est essayée c'est
ici dans la c'est un produit poutine est
un produit soviétique poutine un ancien
du kgb il n'y a pas de vaccin contre
contre poutine comme contre l'accueil
des essais c'est malheureux mais c'est
ça
et vous parlez dans le reportage dans
notre entrevue du pardon quand on voit
ce qui se passe en ukraine et ça revient
beaucoup depuis une dizaine de jours les
ukrainiens 10 on pardonne reprendre en
oublierait procès parce que là on est
dans le vif l'a l'appelée loeb ça fait
mal si si si stif rien j'ai fait que ces
gens là vivent vous perdez tout tout
tout tout était vous courir dans la rue
vous vous risquez de vous faire tirer
comme un comme un lapin
il ya plein de cadavres partout qui
change par terre on n'a même pas le
temps les enterre un sais pas où
c'est un beau minable c'est absolument
un ménage je ne veux il ya une chose que
je comprends pas beaucoup c'est poutine
a une arme dissuasive
tout le monde est dissuadé europe latex
patients mais les hôtes ont les uns ces
armes initiative on n'arrive pas à le
dissuader avec nos armes
pour les autres il sait que s'il
n'attaque pas un pays de l'otan
les américains le temps ne va pas
répliquer mais la ccc la folie de ce
conflit là c'est qu'on regarde
impuissant au tour parce que si ça
pourrait être pire ici tout ça
s'enflamme et que ça se met à s'envoyer
des bombes destructrices
on peut même pas imaginer jusqu'à quel
point ça présentait pas de garantie on
ne sait pas s'il va pas répudier sur un
bouton puis voilà ça va ça va sauter
et malheureusement c'est ça c'est
désespérant moi je vous jure et des
nuits que je passe vraiment tu me
manques blanche j'ai fait des cauchemars
je sais ça n'a jamais été évacuées de
mon esprit ce que j'ai vécu j'imagine ce
que j'ai ces gens là vivent aujourd'hui
c'est c'est abominable et c'est
absolument atroce il y avait cette photo
je sais pas si on l'est on a vu des
images de sur le quai des gens qui
attendent et c'est exactement ce que
vous décrivez quand vous êtes partie de
ce qui est arrivé sur un quai et c'est
l'inconnue c'est le plongeon dans
l'inconnu et vous les comprenez mieux
que n'importe qui ici cg on arrive dans
un pays étranger qui vont nous
accueillent ici bien mais tout est à
refaire on rêve on va rêver une vie
nouvelle vie on rêve à la vie
on oublie la mort on essaie de plus
jamais y penser en espérant que cette
menace la n'arrivera plus mais elle
arrive à l'estanquet merci merci pour
l'entrevue merci d'être vivant en studio
merci je vous souhaite beaucoup de
livres encore puis beaucoup de rire
encore malgré tout mais aussi parce que
ça reste va merci beaucoup